asked
the hell is that guy
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's born and
right now everybody is talking about the
Black Widow special look that we got the
other day during the college national
championship specifically everybody is
freaking out about taskmaster the big
question right now is who is taskmaster
a lot of people are thinking that
taskmasters figure looks a little bit
like a female figure
so the theories begin could it be Black
Widow sister Yelena Bulova or could even
be Melania basta cough heck it could
even be Tony Stark himself all right
just get over here no no it's not ignore
that but there was a big leak and theory
that was presented yesterday of who
taskmaster could be and it makes a lot
of sense the supposedly can big theory
right now is that Angelina Jolie's
eternal character FINA is taskmaster
now before you brush this theory off you
can actually argue a pretty good case
that she is in fact taskmaster and it
actually lines up with something that
Kevin Feige has recently said in an
interview about the Eternals and it fits
into the nfinity saga involving multiple
Avengers pretty well so in this video
I'll talk about every single reason that
this theory makes sense
who taskmaster is and then at the end of
the video you can decide for yourself on
if you actually think that thena is
taskmaster be sure to subscribe with
notifications turned on so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or ps4 I'm picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
now this leak and now theory all started
last night from a Twitter account called
smart Tom smart Thomas posted some leaks
in the past and has gotten a lot of
attention and is now really getting
attention with the latest leak that he
posted and last night's smart Tom posted
a tweet that said
potentially huge spoilers after the
Black Widow movie trailer dropped
everyone is trying to figure out who is
under the taskmaster mask well my ears
heard it is in fact one of the Eternals
who has been watching The Avengers since
NAT dumped shields files to the web he
thing goes on to say it's very possible
Angelina Jolie's thena is actually
taskmaster
the hell is that guy now there is no way
of telling if this leak is actually
legitimate but despite what smart Tom
says there are at least five legitimate
reasons that this theory could be true
so for reason number one about why this
theory actually makes sense let's talk
about what Kevin Feige said about the
Eternals in a recent interview Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
said that the Eternals have been in
hiding they've been in hiding on the
earth and they know who the Avengers are
but the Avengers do not know who they
are
so clearly the Eternals whose main
purpose is to protect the earth and the
humans on it have been watching the
Avengers and one of the main things
about taskmaster that we finally saw in
this special look is that taskmaster has
the ability to observe and then mimic
the exact fighting and combat style of
whoever he's fighting but in the special
look he actually mimics more than one
character obviously he mimics Black
Widow in the final scene of the trailer
where they're both on the floor and then
they push themselves up but if you look
at the times that you see him in the
trailer he actually mimics other people
such as Captain America when he's
holding the shield he then throws the
shield and looks just like Captain
America as well and then in the first
trailer that we got he had a bow and he
looked exactly like Hawkeye in fact many
people have theorized that he is Hawkeye
however at this point in time Hawkeye is
on house arrest and he's with his family
so that disproves the theory then in one
scene where he's flipping over Natasha
while holding the shield it kind of
looks like spider-man and it also kind
of looks like black panther in another
scene where he comes down in a tacks
black widow with his sword it kind of
looks like Thor flying through the air
with his hammer so it looks like
taskmaster is copying some of the other
Avengers as fighting styles that means
that whoever taskmaster is would have
had to monitored the Avengers he would
have had to seen these fighting styles
in action in order to analyze them and
copy them and as we've learned from
Kevin Feige the Eternals know of the
Avengers and they have been watching
them another reason that this could be
thena is because there's been so much
secrecy around who taskmaster is we
literally have tons of leaked photos
from the set of Black Widow we have
leaked photos of pretty much everybody
leaked photos of Scarlett Johansson as
Black Widow Florence Pugh even
Thunderbolt Ross but we have zero
of taskmaster without the helmet dawn
this is being kept a huge secret and is
kind of a priority for Marvel Studios
right now but why why is it such a big
reveal well it could be because that's
actually Angelina Jolie behind the mask
but another thing to look at is how
exactly does taskmaster fit into the
story of Black Widow at this point in
time it's looking like he's not really
the main villain of the film in fact
there are many different plot leaks that
say Molina Bostic off is the main
villain they say that she is the one
that's actually trying to keep the Black
Widow program going while Jelena Bulova
and Black Widow try to take it down so
if this is true then taskmaster is kind
of a side story to the movie and the big
question is if taskmaster really is
Angelina Jolie's eternal character
Athena doesn't fit into the story of
Black Widow yes it does once again as
Kevin Feige said the Eternals know who
the Avengers are and the biggest
question to debunk this theory is that
if the Eternals know who the Avengers
are why would thena attack Black Widow
but this question can easily be answered
in a way that makes perfect sense the
Avengers were involved in every event
that almost resulted in the world being
destroyed and again it's the Eternals
job to protect the world so Black Widow
was involved in the Battle of New York
in the first Avengers film where Loki
came with Thanos's army and the world
was almost taken over and then in
Captain America Winter Soldier she
dumped all of shields files on the
internet for everybody to see and
instantly became on the world's radar
and then consequently the Eternals radar
if the Eternals were monitoring the
future threats of the earth and they
knew who the Avengers are then Black
Widow definitely got on their radar then
then an age of Ultron the Avengers
created Ultron who almost destroyed the
earth technically it was just Tony and
Bruce but on the outside The Avengers
created Ultron and then in Captain
America Civil War right before the
events of the Black Widow film take
place she helped Bucky escape who at
that time the world believed had just
bombed the United Nations and killed the
king of Wakanda now if you're an eternal
and your job is to protect the earth and
you're looking from the outside in it
could very well look like Black Widow is
an enemy and not to mention in the Black
Widow movie she's going to be on the run
as a
felon now one thing to know about thena
out of all the Eternals she is a warrior
she's a very strong and a very skilled
killer so if somebody was going to go
after Black Widow it would probably be
her now the Eternals are practically
gods they're essentially immortal beings
with superhuman strength and abilities
so if she really did go after Black
Widow it probably wouldn't be much of a
fight unless she's actually not sure if
Black Widow is indeed bad again on the
outside it doesn't really look too good
for Black Widow she was a trained
assassin who was killed many different
people throughout her life she was
involved in all of the main events that
almost resulted in the world being
destroyed and now she's a wanted felon
throughout the whole entire world it
looks really bad for her but an eternal
is a very very intellectual being all of
the Eternals are geniuses so thena would
probably be aware that Black Widow could
very well be good and in all of these
events with the exception of her being a
trained assassin she was simply trying
to protect the earth so this could be a
test for Black Widow and ultimately
Athena will go on to realize that Black
Widow isn't actually a threat to the
earth but is a hero and this falls into
a few different plot leaks that actually
say taskmaster is going to die in the
film
now although Marvel does have a tendency
to kill off some other best villains
perhaps taskmaster doesn't actually die
if it is thena all along and she
ultimately discovers that through Black
Widow trying to take down the Black
Widow program and save the lives of many
different women that Natasha Romanoff is
in fact a good person then she might
fake her death her job would be done her
job would have been to take out Black
Widow if she was indeed a threat to the
world but upon finding out that she's
not simply fakes her death and then
taskmaster goes away and she goes about
her business so there are many different
ways that they could actually work FINA
being taskmaster into the Black Widow
story and into the story of the MCU but
would Kevin Feige and Marvel Studios
actually do this and the answer to that
is absolutely the Eternals is going to
be a really big movie for Marvel Studios
Marvel Studios has a lot riding on this
movie and it's actually kind of a risk
for them however not many people really
know who the Eternals are or have any
idea of what they're about and that's
why Kevin Feige has absolutely star
studded the cast but there still needs
to be more hype for the movie and what
better way to have more
for the movie then to introduce thena as
taskmaster in the first movie of phase 4
this would definitely make people who
are not interested in seeing the
Eternals want to go see the movie they
would want to know what they're all
about and it would definitely help so
there are many different reasons on how
this could work and why Marvel Studios
would do this but having said that is
taskmaster actually thena despite all
the logic and reasoning she's most
likely not I would love it if she was I
think it would be an insanely good idea
but despite all of that logic and
reasoning I still don't think it's going
to happen
however with Marvel Studios as we all
know anything is possible
so I want you to let me know what you
think about this theory list your
reasons on why this theory could be true
and why this theory may not be true in
the comments down below if you think
that taskmaster really is thena let me
know why and if you don't think it's
thena let me know who you think
taskmaster actually is so leave all your
thoughts and theories in the comments
down below and also don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to my channel to
stay up to date on all things related to
the MCU including theories and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 I'm picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]